For 2015, the countdown is on for the release of the much-anticipated Apple watch.
The watch is gonna have to be one part fashion accessory...
...one part indisposable piece of information equipment.
But wearable tech won't just be for your wrist.
The cordless Dash earphones will play music as well as track steps and heart rate.
And it's your body's biometrics that could replace passwords.
The Nymi armband uses your heartbeat to unlock devices and make payments,...
...while the Zwipe credit card has a built-in fingerprint sensor.
Your home will also get smarter with more connected appliances.
For cars, virtual rearview mirrors will come into focus.
Nissan and Cadillac are looking to replace the mirrors with the display for rearview cameras.
For the latest gadget news and reviews, visit cnet.com.